تعتمد مصر على أوكرانيا وروسيا
في ما لا يقل عن ثلث 10 ملايين
سائح يزورون البلاد كل عام ،
حيث انخفضت السياحة بنسبة مئوية من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
من 32 مليار دولار في عام 2019 إلى 14.4
مليار دولار في عام 2020 ، وهو انخفاض ناجم
عن الوباء الذي
تسبب فيه الوباء الاقتصادي في مصر.
اتخذت الدولة إجراءات مؤلمة لخفض قيمة
عملتها وإصلاح اقتصادها في يونيو من
هذا العام ، لجأت إلى البنك الدولي
للحصول على قرض بقيمة 500 مليون دولار ،
ويتوقع المحللون الآن ارتفاعًا في
الاستثمارات الخاصة والصادرات
، ويشجع جزء كبير من ذلك على الاستثمار
الأجنبي المباشر  الاستثمار في
طليعة تلك الإستراتيجية هي رانيا
مشاط وزيرة التعاون الدولي في مصر.
جلست معها
لمعرفة ما الذي تسير عليه خطة مصر إلى الأمام.
أريد أن أبدأ من حيث تقف مصر
الآن من الناحية الاقتصادية رأينا ارتفاعًا
في التضخم نحن قلقون.  فيما يتعلق بالحبوب ،
نحن قلقون بشأن تكلفة الوقود
ولكنك في نفس الوقت تعاني
من ألم قصير الأمد عليك صيانته
نركز على المدى الطويل على كيفية
موازنة هذه المعضلة منذ 2014
استثمرت مصر في صوامع لتخزين القمح
لم يكن لدينا ذلك من قبل أيضًا
استثمرنا في زيادة الأراضي الزراعية
وكان القمح جزءًا من ذلك ، لذلك عندما
حدثت هذه الأزمة كانت هناك
سعة تخزينية و  كما كان هناك 50 في المائة
من استهلاكنا المحلي من الإنتاج المحلي ،
لذلك هذا أه عندما
يكون لدولة ما رؤية يمكنها مواجهة
صدمات مختلفة يمكن أن تخلق تلك
المرونة ، كل الرسوم التي
ذكرتها تتطلب تمويلًا هائلاً بشكل
صحيح وخلال هذا الوقت حيث  ترى
أنك تعرف الألم الاقتصادي وعدم اليقين
كيف يمكنك التأكد من وجود
مساحة مالية دائمًا لتمويل هذه الأنواع من المشاريع الضخمة ،
لذا فأنت تدعو الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر ، فأنت
تدعو إلى الاستغناء عن مشاريع الطاقة
تبدو مثيرة للغاية ، هل تعتقد أن
مصر تستند إلى حد ما  في وضع
مختلف
تمامًا لتكون قادرًا على جذب هذا
النوع من المال ، لذا فهناك عدد قليل من
المؤشرات المهمة عندما ننظر إلى
البلدان التي تحاول  إلى الأمام في
جداول أعمال التنمية الخاصة بهم ،
توفر ميزانية الدورة التدريبية موردًا رئيسيًا ولكن أيضًا
استثمارات القطاع الخاص
مهمة وكذلك الشراكات الدولية مع
بنوك التنمية متعددة الجنسيات وشركاء التنمية ،
لذلك هناك
أنواع مختلفة من التمويل
عندما يتعلق الأمر
بريادة الأعمال والابتكار يقول ماشات أن مستقبل مصر
يتطلع  مشرق قطاع المعلومات
والتكنولوجيا قويا يسجل
نموا أعلى في الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للبلاد
بين عامي 2020 و 2021 نما القطاع بنسبة 16
في المائة باستثمارات ثلاثة مليارات دولار
بين عامي 2019 و 2020
ارتفع القطاع بنسبة 15.2 في المائة لذلك لدينا
ديموغرافية تماما أه  رائع
60 من السكان الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 30 عامًا
الابتكار والإبداع موجودون للوصول
إلى المساحات الرقمية هناك ، وبالتالي فإن
ما رأيناه خلال السنوات القليلة الماضية
هو مشهد ناشئ نابض بالحياة ومتطور
بينما هناك العديد من التحديات هناك
تفاؤل عام لا يخلو من
تحدياتها وريادة الأعمال  حول
التحديات التي يجب أن تبدأ في أي حال
تواجه الأسواق الناشئة تحديات متميزة
حول رأس المال الكافي
عبر الطيف الترددي وتعليم
أسواق جديدة للتكنولوجيا ولكن هذا
حقبة جديدة من النجاح أعتقد في مصر
الآن وأيضًا من خلال الشرق الأوسط
والأسواق الناشئة المصرية  الشركات
لا تنظر فقط إلى مصر ولكن
المنطقة وما بعدها ، وأعتقد أنه
يتعين علينا أن نتذكر أنه في حين أن
تحديات بنيتها التحتية في أي
سوق ناشئة وإلى حد كبير في أي مكان
بشكل عام في أماكن مثل التعليم
والصحة وعناصر التكنولوجيا والتكنولوجيا
الداعمة للأشياء المالية  في
نهاية اليوم ، حيث تكمن الفرصة
وأعتقد أن رواد الأعمال المصريين
يقودون إلى ذلك بجدية تامة
ويقودون الحكومة المصرية
التي لا تزال
تركز على قطاعات النمو في أوقات
عدم اليقين الهائلة التي
تتطور البيئة العالمية وقد
كانت كذلك.  يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا للجميع ولكن
ما رأيناه مؤخرًا هو
r  التخفيض في أسعار الوقود وأسعار المواد الغذائية
الذي يخلق بعض الراحة ،
وهو أمر مهم للغاية هو أننا
نمضي قدمًا في
إصلاحات هيكلية مختلفة ستفتح أيضًا
فرصًا للاستثمار في القطاعات ، لذا
أعتقد أن مصر أظهرت على مر السنين قدرًا كبيرًا من
المرونة  وهذا شيء
نشعر به على الرغم من السقطات ، إلا أن هناك مسارًا متوسطًا
إلى طويل المدى نثق به كثيرًا
بشأن
الأجانب